[Music]
on this wednesday night more financial
help from the feds for businesses
drowning in the fifth wave
we've been in a poverty situation who's
eligible for the new pandemic benefits
with money and patience running out
we're probably going to dip into family
savings
quebec cracks down while saskatchewan
stays the course the patchwork of
provincial responses as omicron cases
climb the nhl benches players from the
beijing olympics what the game changer
could mean for team canada plus santa's
village prepares for a covid christmas i
know there has been lockdowns and
everything a message from saint nick on
seeing the upside of a lockdown
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us just days away from christmas and for
the second year in a row the pandemic is
putting a damper on the holiday cheer
the prime minister addressed the country
today alongside canada's top doctor and
cabinet ministers announcing new
benefits and other measures to combat
the climbing caseload across canada
there are now more than 2 300 confirmed
cases of omicron and take a look at just
how fast this highly contagious variant
is spreading late last week canada was
reporting an average of 5 000 new covet
cases every day well yesterday there
were more than eleven thousand that
daily case count doubling in just a few
days quebec remains the provincial hot
spot reporting more than six thousand
new cases and it expects to announce
more than nine thousand tomorrow that
province announced measures on monday
shutting down schools and some
businesses and quebec went even further
tonight restricting indoor gatherings to
six people or two family bubbles over
christmas
i ask you to please
cancel your christmas parties if you can
if you choose to go ahead please gather
only on the 24 or on the 25th
and most important thing is to be very
very careful with people over the age of
60.
for those businesses and workers caught
in the crackdown the federal government
announced more financial help is on the
way but as ann gaviola reports it may be
too little too late
i think it was a very hollow response i
think they could have done more and done
more immediately three of the 60 staff
at barbarian steakhouse in toronto
recently tested positive for kovid
forcing it to shut down tuesday for at
least 10 days during what was gearing up
to be a busy holiday season
aaron barbarian who runs the restaurant
that's been a fixture since 1959
says nearly two years into this pandemic
it's saddled with debt and obligations
like rent and utilities the extra
federal support is a lifeline but
because it's structured as a rebate the
money won't flow until february we are
adrift at sea right now and we need we
need them to come and help us right now
once again we're probably going to dip
into family savings
to keep everybody
to keep everybody afloat it's a very
very difficult time new federal dollars
will be made available to employers
dealing with capacity restrictions of 50
percent or more they have to show
revenue declines of at least 25 percent
and eligible employers can get wage and
rent subsidies ranging from 25 to 75
percent
there's also expanded support for
workers who previously weren't eligible
because there are no official lockdowns
in place
though the service entertainment and
hospitality industries are struggling
with reduced customers and income
because of new and ongoing restrictions
think of this as the new serb
broader lockdown benefits will now apply
to workers in areas with capacity
restrictions of 50
the benefit is 300 a week for those
who've lost 50 or more of their income
until may
the canadian chamber of commerce is
calling on ottawa to let businesses know
about repayment terms for federal loans
which remain a question mark after last
week's fiscal update two years in
businesses are
cash trapped they're you know maxed out
on their debt they don't have those
reserves anymore that they may have had
earlier in the pandemics
for establishments like barbarians this
wave is a brutal reminder that with the
pandemic's impact on health comes a
fresh toll on businesses too
ann gaviola global news toronto
besides more funding the federal
government was also offering reassurance
today that ottawa is prepared for this
fifth wave but at the same time the
prime minister revealed that kovid 19
has infected his own inner circle
michael couture has the details
but omicron is here and we're just going
to have to hunker down and be careful
practicing what he's preaching prime
minister justin trudeau addressed
canadians from his home because three
members of his staff and three security
detail tested positive for covid19
trudeau says he's tested negative but
has been told to limit his contacts we
can't prevent every case we can't
actually detect every case necessarily
because of the sheer numbers in the from
the provinces and territories dr teresa
tam says the key is to prevent any
further impacts on long-term care
facilities and hospitals which have
already been stretched to the limit
we're having some concerns about
manpower you know that's related to
you know the the burnout and then the
relative exodus of many health care
providers
each province is responding differently
to the threat of omicron manitoba
reported its largest case count since
may a day after announcing new capacity
limits
while newfoundland and labrador raised
its alert level imposing 50 percent
capacity limits on funerals weddings and
other gatherings today we need to face
things as they are not as we want them
to be
we will reassess where we are on january
10th to determine if we can change the
alert level
in bc there's a run on booster shots and
rapid antigen tests with people lining
up for hours hoping to get access it is
going to be two to three hours i think
to get tested so be prepared yeah be
prepared to wait prime minister trudeau
has said there will be enough boosters
and rapid tests for everyone even though
the availability and administration has
differed depending on where you live
we're delivering more
rapid tests now
35 million throughout this month with
tens of millions more and they can't
come soon enough for many who have
endured nearly two and a half years of
lockdowns and limitations and are now
facing the prospect of another winter
holiday
away from family
jeff
michael couture in ottawa thanks mike
while many provinces are moving forward
with new pandemic restrictions
saskatchewan is not officials there are
asking people to gather safely over the
holidays but there are no new measures
both saskatchewan and alberta were hit
hard by the delta-fueled fourth wave and
as heather york's west reports new
modeling suggests the prairies could be
in for another rough winter
as the omicron grinch steals christmas
across many parts of the country there
is one province heading into the
holidays virtually restriction free our
case numbers are you know the lowest or
second lowest in canada
and we worked hard to reach that and we
have we don't have widespread omicron
transmission right now saskatchewan
residents can gather as they wish this
christmas even as new modeling warns of
an incoming omicron surge according to
projections released by the saskatchewan
government tuesday without any new
health measures intensive care units
will begin to fill a gain through the
month of january that's before the
province has fully recovered from the
previous wave i would have obviously
liked to have seen some proactive
measures taken in terms of cutting
capacity at restaurants bars nightclubs
and so forth as well as some indoor
gathering limits so that we could try
and slow this down a little bit these
are largely focused at avoiding super
spreader events on tuesday the alberta
government introduced new rules limiting
capacity for large events venues that
hold more than a thousand people are
limited to 50 percent capacity consuming
food and drinks is not permitted in
seated seated audience situations in
large venues or during intermission the
province also encouraging albertans to
reduce their contacts and keep holiday
gatherings small though hours after the
measures were announced the united
conservative party held a holiday party
in edmonton
organizers say it followed all current
guidelines but a second event planned
for calgary on wednesday has now been
canceled the omicron grinch strikes
again
heather urex west global news calgary
and it's the news hockey fans have been
dreading the nhl just confirmed that its
pro players will not be competing in the
beijing olympics in february the league
is blaming the pandemic for the decision
and the move is also prompting bigger
questions about whether it's safe for
the games to happen at all ross lord
reports
covet 19 infections have forced the
national hockey league to postpone more
than 50 games and take an early holiday
break now hockey's best players are
going to sit out even more marquee
match-ups at february's beijing olympics
in a statement nhl commissioner gary
bettman said olympic participation is no
longer feasible and that current
circumstances have made it impossible
for us to proceed despite everyone's
best efforts
instead the league will use the two-week
olympic period for games it's been
forced to reschedule the canadian
olympic committee will need to find
other players to wear the team canada
jersey the committee says it's excited
to rally behind the men's team for its
first game on february 10th but as all
nhl players know there are persistent
questions about whether beijing should
go ahead at all over human rights
violations and because of omicron and
the potential health risks the olympics
as a whole i'm sure
there's a lot of conversations you know
being had about that so admit you know
we'll have to just see kind of what
happens but uh
yeah it's
a lot of a lot of moving parts right now
several countries including canada have
announced a diplomatic boycott but there
were calls for canada to boycott the
games entirely the athletes have the
power to do something and they need to
do the right thing here and whether it
doesn't happen for this games they need
to use their athletes commission they
need to
go ahead and and hold the ioc
accountable for going to these places at
this point canada's top women's hockey
players are still going to beijing a
statement from hockey canada says plans
remain the same as we continue to
prepare
another best against best hockey
tournament is still on the annual world
junior championship in edmonton and red
deer alberta over the christmas holidays
despite the widespread omicron variant
spectators are permitted although
government rules have forced organizers
to cut seating capacity to 50 percent
for all games
the ebbs and flows of the pandemic
making it tough to hit the target in
canada's national winter pastime
ross lord global news
still ahead a stunning story of survival
the extraordinary lengths a madagascar
minister went to get to safety after a
helicopter crash
[Music]
at least one person is dead and dozens
missing after a landslide in myanmar it
happened at a jade mine in the country's
north officials fear around 80 people
may have been swept into the lake deadly
landslides are common in the mining
region just last weekend at least six
people were killed in another slide
in madagascar a government minister has
lived to tell quite the tale after a
helicopter crash
that is the country's secretary of state
for police explaining how he swam 12
hours to safety after the crash on
monday he was reportedly on route to
inspect a shipwreck when the chopper
went down he said he and another man
were able to eject themselves and both
then made the marathon swim to shore
in japan for the time being big macs
will only be served with small fries
starting friday mcdonald's is taking
medium and large-sized fries off the
menu at its 2900 locations in japan and
that's because potatoes are in short
supply the food giant says the bc floods
have slowed shipments from the port of
vancouver and as a result the potato
portions will be limited to small sizes
only until december the 30th
ahead omicron q a from how much
protection boosters provide to fears for
the immuno compromised our experts
tackle your questions next
some good news from south africa where
omicron was first discovered case counts
are down 20 percent in the last week and
hospitalization from omicron appears to
be lower than the delta variant that
analysis is part of a study from south
africa's national public health
institute and it found the risk of
hospital admission was about 80 percent
lower than delta the study has not been
peer reviewed and the authors cautioned
the findings don't account for the
country's relatively young population
and high levels of immunity
but if omicron is indeed less deadly
what does that mean for the pandemic
moving forward to help answer that
question and others that we've received
from our viewers we are joined now by
two infectious diseases specialists dr
lisa barrett from dalhousie university
and dr anna banerjee from the university
of toronto doctors thank you both so
much for joining us very nice to see you
um dr barrett let's start with you this
first question comes from carla and sort
of picks up on that point she notes that
omicron appears to be milder than delta
and if omicron has taken over why isn't
that a good thing will omicron
eventually just burn itself out what do
you think
well wouldn't we all love to know the
answer to will it just burn itself out i
don't think we know the answer to that
yet
but it does appear that while omicron
does transmit more easily among the
population
it may be there are early signs that it
may be somewhat less likely to cause
hospitalization
than did its previous sibling delta
however the data are early
and there's differing data from
differing countries south africa
different than denmark and even in
denmark there was still about 0.5
of people who got infected
that were still showing up in a hospital
and that sounds like a low percentage
but if you have half a million people
infected then point five percent is a
lot of people in hospital at the one
time which is why we still care
even if it's not as severe
about people getting a lot of infections
in the population at the same time
yeah excellent point and speaking of a
lot of infections uh next question to
you dr banerjee if omicron is indeed
more contagious are we at risk of
becoming infected from limited exposure
like someone jogging past you on the
street for example
so someone well talking past you it's a
very short period of time
and it's outdoors and assuming you're
assuming you're lost so the risks are
really minimal it's really when you're
more indoors
and you're sharing the same air space as
someone else that's really when you're
at higher risk and if you're not using
mass so
someone running by you i'm not too
concerned about that
okay good to know uh dr barrett back
over to you now this next question
coming from joanne and of course we've
heard over and over again our best
weapon against omicron is that booster
shot but how much less likely are we to
become infected and to spread covet 19
once we've had our booster
yeah we're still working on that at the
moment i think the data are out there
and there are bits and pieces of
information that are coming from the
companies that make these vaccines and
they're looking in the lab at how likely
it is for the virus to be shut down if
you will by the antibodies that these
vaccines produce however that's early
data the real world data what happens in
humans as we move through this is still
less clear to me however it does look
like a booster will be helpful
in adding extra protection to preventing
against
some of those serious outcomes i want to
make two things clear though number one
infection is different
than serious disease and death and we do
know that omicron can still infect so
that's a little bit why we're still
taking some of those public health
precautions
and number two
even with two doses if you haven't quite
gotten your booster yet it's still quite
effective even with omicron at
preventing serious outcomes so you can't
use it as the only tool vaccination that
is but you can use it as a good tool
and particularly after the booster dose
exact numbers of protection yet to come
but never a bad idea if you have access
to it
okay we're almost at a time here dr
banerjee but this is one of the most
common questions we've received from
elizabeth who like many others of course
is immunocompromised and wondering
whether she'll need a fourth dose of the
vaccine and if so when
so we don't really know yet we don't
know if it's going to be a booster dose
every year booster or if the vaccine is
going to change it might be possible in
vanessa while they start taking instead
of the original alpha string they start
um making the newer versions of the
vaccine including like the alpha the uh
omocron et cetera but depending on what
strains of circling so we don't know if
it's going to be a booster or a new set
of vaccines that may come in the future
but i i assume it will be there will be
some kind of uh vaccine in the future
yeah and we've heard just this week from
israel which is now moving forward with
plans to start offering a fourth shot to
people over the age of 60. so we shall
see doctors lisa barrett dr anna
banerjee thank you so much for joining
us really appreciate it
and we'll be putting questions about
omicron to the experts all week so
please send us yours to your questions
at globalnews.ca
ho ho hoping for visitors next the
pandemics effect on tourism at santa's
village
coveted 19 is cancelling a lot of
holiday plans but as any kid will tell
you santa claus is an essential worker
but even jolly old saint nick is not
immune from the effects of the pandemic
tourism at santa's village in finland is
taking a huge hit but as redmond shannon
reports even the pandemic can't dampen
santa's christmas spirit
lots of nice and good children waiting
for us he's checked it all twice the
sleigh is ready the reindeer are fed and
the presents are piled up christmas
preparations are going quite well at the
moment
it's only a few days till christmas now
the elves have been working very hard as
always trust santa to see an upside to
lockdowns i know there has been
lockdowns and everything and people have
been together at the houses but
i wish that people should do do things
together more
as the big man gets ready for takeoff
his very own holiday village in lapland
is welcoming visitors from around the
world
a festive finnish paradise in ice
sitting on the edge of the arctic circle
i'm 48 and it's my first time here and i
wanted to visit santa claus and i'm
happy to come for the first time with my
kids very christmassy
everyone is super nice but it's really
cold
this second covert christmas had many
visitors thinking twice before booking
actually to the very last minute until
we boarded the plane
then once we the plane took off we said
okay we're fine honestly speaking we
thought about that but
everyone seems to be fascinated and you
get a hope you lucky enough just to make
it through and
well
so far so good omicron has driven record
new coveted case numbers in finland new
travel and testing restrictions have
punctured the rebound lapland locals had
hoped for i think the bigger question is
from the feeder markets do they let the
people out and come back again you can't
trust anything
you have to just wait and see what
happens so it's
quite
quite stressful an underlying anxiety in
a place of wonder
but the busiest workers of all are
taking hope from those who matter most
some kid wishes that the pandemic will
end soon and so say all of us redmond
shannon global news london
and that is global national for this
wednesday night i'm jeff semple we leave
you tonight with this special sunrise at
stonehenge in the uk crowds of people
gathered this morning to mark the winter
solstice thanks for watching have a
great night
[Music]
you